[Music]
in today's eight on your side many of
you might be savvy shoppers when it
comes to groceries kids clothing home
furnishings but how about
health and wellness i feel like this is
the perfect sweet spot
to start establishing some new smart
shopping and money saving habits moving
forward
accomplished lifestyle expert trey bonge
specializes in smart shopping she says
many people tend to forget to maximize
their savings when it comes to this area
of their life
but you can start right now on health
and wellness by making sure you fill out
that loyalty sheet at your pharmacy
so you're accruing those points and
getting those special discounts
as well as getting your hands on one of
these
there's something called a prescription
card this is from optumrx and
this is a free card that you can order
online and it gives you access to
prescription discounts at over 66 000
pharmacies
around the country and then if you
happen to have an aarp membership
you can use it with that card and save
even
more so badge turned 52 this year she
says many people may not realize like
herself that they're eligible for these
benefits she says aarp is for anyone 50
years of age and older
a full membership is only 16 bucks a
year and she says with it
you can access major savings in the
health and wellness area
including 50 off prescription glasses in
addition to many
other services